what else luck is this legal diagnose we
go straight primeval your ass with heart
of darkness by Joseph Conrad as he
chilling on the Thames river with some
homies my boy Charles Marlow start
talking about some dark business he saw
while hustling and ivory trade see back
in the day Marlo got hooked up trade in
ivory up in the African Congo for some
crew called the company and this gang
full of sheisty fools just sitting on
their asses waiting for Marlo get the
word that he gonna howl at Aegina
Beijing named Kurtz living at the inner
station but the only rider got is a
busted ass steamboat so I have to give
him this ride pimp Marlo starts his
journey towards Kurtz when it comes to
slinging that clean ivory to make slow
dollars this fool curse got the whole
Congo sold up and all the other brothers
hating on him since he ballin so long
just as Marlo cruising up the Kurtz pot
arrows start flying out of nowhere and
the helmsman gets straight lit up after
Marlo escaped he scopes of rushing
wearing some dopey as dunce
who said Kurtz ain't you every day
hustler nah the natives worshipping
Kurtz like mr. big up ahead
meaning Kurtz can do whatever he pleased
turns out it was Kurtz who ordered the
attack of Marlo's whip when Marlow meets
the big dog he sees that he's ill in
more ways than one
Marlow convinced his curse to truck it
back to Europe but he keeps getting
sicker till he spits his last words and
then he closed like a [ __ ] with Marlow
back in Europe
he makes us stop to see Kurtz's lady
when she asks about his final words
Marlow lies and says that Kurtz used his
last breath to say her name
I slick if you got your together you
know that most people say hld
representing a de senator he met at he's
evil nature as Marlowe flowing upriver
and it's all well-read thugs know that
journey slinging ambiguity and Paragon
something in like Scarface swinging that
yeah yeah
for example encourages away from society
for too long
he gets all whacked out in the head and
start doing some notorious deeds but at
the same time society with all this
crooked imperialism doing vicious put on
the red cuz it's the eyes of
civilization that keeps you mad at ease
darkness and check but when we
surrounded by the silent whisper of the
wilderness
we straight lose ourselves to the dark
it's only then that we ain't got no
man-made code to tell us what's what and
we start getting straight nasty now I
mean on the real both human beings and
society decked out with enough evil
inside to inspire all that hard Kurt's
talking about
but what skirts really trying to say
with those last words not only is Kurt's
referring to his old dark deeds but the
beastly evil aside to harden early
hustler cuz in the wilderness that evil
got nowhere to hide
civilization though be y'all shady bad
and it's sweeps that under the rug like
it's all good
peep this quote from Matthew 23 woe unto
you hypocrites for ye are like unto
whited Sepulcher which indeed appear
beautiful outward but are within full of
dead men's bones and of all uncleanness
even so ye also outwardly appear
righteous unto men but within ye are
full of hypocrisy and iniquity so when
Marlo say a city look like a whited
Sepulcher he really saying that is full
of crooked Buster's friend like they
civilized but it's not boy Marlo one of
these hypocrites cuz this fool say he
hates the line there is a ton of death a
flavour of mortality in lies which is
exactly what I hated to test in the
world yet at the end of the novella he
lies to Kurt's woman like it ain't no
thing
why like the hero of the mythic journey
Marlow returns from the dead deaths in
Hades with info that's supposed to make
the world a better place and since he
realized that the darkness that lie
beneath is just enough for Curtis Benny
to bear he lies
sometimes there are more important
things than stick it straight to the
truth you feel me you know thanks for
being a realist audience on YouTube make
sure you subscribe and hit me up next
week play
[Music]